all right howdy everybody thanks for uh
joining me today uh we're just gonna get
kicked off here um wait a couple minutes
for some folks to roll in but
excited to be talking to you today about
building packages in r
uh my name is tom mock i'm a customer
enablement lead in our studio and i'll
be talking a little bit about uh
everything we're doing today
and let's
see what time it is we're about 9 a.m
central standard time where i am in
texas but it'd be great to hear from
the
chat in terms of where everyone else is
coming from or
if you're in the us or the uk or africa
or europe or where else ever you're from
i'll probably wait another minute or so
and then we'll jump into uh the slides
i'll share that link real quick in terms
of
the github repository with all of my
code and slides from today
and then a link directly to
the slides themselves
awesome uh looks like some folks from
the us we got new jersey maine some
folks from canada switzerland chicago
mumbai
brazil fantastic very cool to get kind
of the the international experience here
so thanks for dialing in from wherever
you are
um as a reminder this is a live stream
so we'll kind of take things as they
come
but it will be hosted up on youtube on
our studios youtube in the future so if
you do have to step out or if a
colleague can't make it today feel free
to send them the link in the future
um
awesome so so cool to see all the
different groups and thanks again for
for joining me today
we're about uh two minutes after the
hour so i'm going to go ahead and get
started um as much as possible feel free
to post questions in the chat i'll see
as much as possible try to answer some
of those
and then again the slides themselves are
going to be linked to uh in the slide
deck so let me go ahead and start
sharing my screen
and
we're going to do a couple things today
i do have our studio open in the back so
we will show a little bit of some live
coding
but we have some slides today that we'll
be covering for most of the time
again the github repository has a link
to the slides as well as to the r
packages book
this is an amazing textbook written by
hadley wickham and jenny bryan from here
at our studio
and they do you know just a great job of
walking through in obviously much
greater depth that we can do even in an
hour of the process of building an art
package
for today we're going to be kind of
walking through end-to-end building
functions building packages and then
hopefully sharing them with others or at
the very least kind of using them within
your own team or within your own
organization
i also want to give a big shout out to
josiah perry he was pretty key in kind
of kicking off this presentation and
kind of the motivation behind it
as well as the idea of like spending
quite a bit of time and talking about
functions because really that's the part
where you have to spend a lot of time
thinking is like what do i want to build
what is my function going to do
and lastly these slides are released
under cc by 2.0 meaning feel free to
refactor them or deliver them to other
people you can reuse these slides as you
see fit
so you're here today hopefully you want
to build an r package um the packages at
the most basic are the fundamental units
of reproducible r code uh they include
reusable r functions the documentation
that describes how to use them and
potentially some sample data
in other words package is a home for
functions and functions and r are a home
for source code
so if we really want to start talking
about packages we really want to start
talking about functions so stating this
a bit differently
functions in r are just wrappers around
longer source code so one line function
in terms of like do this as your
function name is actually calling quite
a bit of our code behind the scenes
and packages are just a way of
describing distributing these functions
in a structured a consistent way so
taking a function that you've written
one time and making it available in
multiple projects or even potentially on
multiple computers if you distribute it
to your colleagues or to yourself on a
different computer
so in reality if you want to build a
package you want to build a home for
functions
and as far as kind of the motivation for
writing these functions and writing
packages it's all about reproducibility
or reusability so reproducibility and
code in some ways is actually all about
being as lazy as possible in a good way
and we'll talk about that throughout
so functions are a way to don't repeat
yourself and be more efficient in terms
of you can use a function multiple times
and you don't have to type out the same
code over and over and over you just use
your function one time or even apply it
multiple times with other functions
it allows you to share workflows and
empower both yourself in terms of i
write packages that are only for me or
you could write function uh
functions and packages that are
empowering the rest of your team to do
work to do their core job functions
they also allow you to test your code
and trust your work or trust others work
who you may not know or you may not be
able to you know you know learn how they
write functions so testing allows you to
make sure that functions work as
intended and that's another part of
writing packages
so ultimately functions make your work
much easier faster and more reproducible
and our packages let you share these
functions and be lazier in a good way in
terms of this idea of like
reproducibility about being as lazy as
possible using functions using packages
so you can recreate that environment as
easily as possible
so i've kind of captured all your
attention now we're going to talk a
little bit about functions in terms of
you have to build functions to build
packages so we actually need to spend
quite a bit of time talking about
functions and how to write them and
motivations behind them and this idea
again shout out to josiah for saying you
know we need to talk a bit more about
functions because the process of
building an r package is actually really
straightforward but thinking about how
to write a function while it can be
straightforward is where people
typically get you know stuck a bit more
so if we kind of describe or look at the
anatomy of a function a function is made
up by a descriptive function name
informing the user of the function's
specific purpose
arguments to that function which control
the output basically i can change these
parameters or these arguments and i get
a novel output so my function can do
multiple things
the body of the function which is all
the source code used internally that
actually you know does all the work but
is hidden by the wrapper around the
function
and then lastly what the function
returns so at some point it stops and it
returns either you know a visible effect
or a silent effect or just returns
something or does something
and if we do this with pseudo code or
basically just like showing some of this
in like our code we have a function name
we have the function kind of wrapper
we have the argument
and then we have the body of the
function and lastly the return so again
a descriptive function name arguments to
the function the body itself and then
what the function returns but let's
actually show this in a real function
we'll talk a little bit about that
so our first function that we're going
to write will be super simple we'll take
it with one argument which will be x
we'll use it to take x and square it
and then we will return that value
so we're going to name it something you
know what it does it squares the value
and it has one argument of x and it
takes x and it passes it to the second
power so it squares it
so now we've written a function we can
pass numbers into it and we get you know
2 squared is 4 16 squared is 256. great
you know we have a very simple function
does exactly what we expect it to do
and you know we're ready to go maybe we
need this function for something else
but what about unintended inputs in
terms of
what if someone passes a string to this
or a list or a plot like what about you
know protecting against these unintended
inputs
so if i take a cat or in this case like
a string saying cat and i try and square
it i get this lovely error function
which is error in cat squared
non-numeric argument to binary operator
now in computer science terms this is
describing exactly what it is
in human terms this is not as helpful as
i'd like it to be
and if i take my function i've just
written and pass a cat to it
i get the same error because it's just
wrapping that r code so non-numeric
argument to binary operator
yikes so let's let's try and make that a
little bit friendlier
so our first function too we're going to
take our function and just you know slap
a 2 on the end of it to say that it's a
second version
and now we're going to add a stop if not
which is basically saying if this is not
true
stop and return this error message
so now if the input is not numeric it
will return the error message of input
must be numeric because the input has to
be numeric per this stop if not
so now if i pass our cat into square val
2 it says input must be numeric and if i
pass numerics into it nothing happens
and it just does what i intended to do
but importantly we've kind of made this
function a little bit more user-friendly
we've really done it with one extra line
of code but it's helped protect us
against unintended inputs and made it
more user-friendly for ourselves and for
people who don't know all the source
code that you've written inside of it
let's go a little bit further with this
though in terms of let's do a little
more complex example
so now we're going to create a function
that generates fake data but
reproducibly in terms of we're going to
generate random data but we want to be
able to reproduce it every time if we
wanted to so we want to have a seed
so a couple things going on here we have
a logical up top
we have two arguments we have the n or
the number of fake data points we want
to create and this with seed argument
if this width seed argument is not null
then it will set the seed with whatever
number we've put in here
the uh other part we're going to do is
we're going to pad some numbers so we're
going to make all the numbers the same
length and we're going to sample in
terms of getting our actual random
numbers we're going to sample from 1 to
the length of the n so 1 through 10
and then we're going to paste together
that padding onto the number with the
random integer that we've sampled
and we'll throw this into a data frame
or a table and generate that out
so this is still you know all normal r
code inside we have two arguments and we
have this null which is based off the
logical
and when we do this with 125 we can now
generate 125 random observations in a
data frame so we could use this for like
simulating data
or or whatever else you know we've just
generated a data frame great
the part about making it reproducible is
i can pass it with a specific seed so
now even though i'm generating 10 random
numbers i have a seed attached to it so
i can generate the same random numbers
uh every single time which is helpful
for doing things like represses or
reproducible examples that's what i use
this type of function for
however if i don't want it to be
reproducible in terms of i really want
random numbers then i can generate it
without a seed and now i have 10 random
numbers that are all different and have
you know different string mismatches so
i can get my fully random out of it as
well
so maybe that's not as motivating to you
i'm just trying to show you that you've
got a couple different arguments in
terms of you can pass things like n you
can pass things like nulls or logicals
and then you can do something called
passing the dots or in multiple params
so in this case
the dots allow us to share
uh basically as many arguments as we
want and pass those into something else
so we can use everything else the same
but now for our randomization it's we're
going to use our norm or normal
distribution uh of random data
and we're going to pass the dots
from the function arguments into this
argument so that means any arguments
that our norm accepts we can put in here
in our function and they will be passed
through
so if you're familiar with our norm it
takes arguments of mean and standard
deviation so even though i haven't
defined those in my function previously
like we don't see you know mean or
standard deviation up here
because these dots have been passed i
can pass these arbitrary arguments into
the internal function so very powerful
in terms of like passing functions back
and forth between things
and now rather than integers i have you
know doubles or
numeric values that can actually have
like decimal places and they all kind of
range around an average of 10 with a
standard deviation of two
so the whole kind of example of this is
this is a function i use all the time in
my own package gt extras specifically
for user comes to me and says like hey i
have an issue i need to reproduce it and
they have like a very specific data set
that they're using so
they have you know a data set with you
know 400 000 as the average i can't use
mt cars for that because their values
are so big
so now i can generate an exact you know
set of values that specify like an exact
mean or exact standard deviation with a
specific number of groups and a specific
length so i can generate very specific
random data sets reproducibly to help
solve my own problems or work with users
to solve their problems in the package
and then this one similarly generates
you know a typical with ids with groups
and with values
so talked a little bit about that
there was a question about dot dots
let's go back here
dot dot is basically called passing the
params or passing the dots so this means
anything that you pass right here at the
end of the function will be captured and
evaluated in this context so when i type
mean and standard deviation here so mean
equals 10 standard deviation equals two
that's actually evaluated right here so
the dots get replaced with those
arguments because i haven't defined them
previously
all right so enough about kind of
generating random data
and we can you know use it for we're
writing functions because we don't want
to repeat ourselves so for this example
absolutely you could use regex or you
could use you know stringer r but let's
not for now
let's say that you have a bunch of
strings that you need to extract the
last few values from
so we could use the base r function
substring
take our string and get the ninth
through the 11th
value so this will get us the last three
digits because this whole string is 11
characters long we can get the 9th 10th
and 11th value of 147.
however if we have a longer value
then we say like wales national 148 this
is not 11 units long it's actually like
16 or 17 units long so if we use the
exact same arguments then it gives us
not what we want we really want to get
these last three values for the id
not the text itself
so we could use this you know existing
function
and write it you know 15 times for all
the different values but then we're
repeating ourselves we want to have
something that we don't have to repeat
ourselves and we can do it the same way
each time so we're not having to reuse a
bunch of code
so maybe we can try and do negatives so
we can say like okay from the end take
from negative 3 to negative 1.
well unfortunately this function doesn't
take negative indices so you can't
actually run it that way
but we can write our own function that
does operate in that way so let's do
that
so substring right is our next function
it has two arguments x and n
and now it's going to take the total
length of the string with number of
characters
it's going to take x which is the first
argument and say how long is the string
it's going to subtract
1 from this total length
and then it's going to count across
these and basically take from the right
side
you know whatever numbers you pass in so
we'll say from three to the end is what
we want to take in
so now this wales national 148
we can actually pass you know three to
this and it will go one two three over
and take just the last three units
because it's counting from the right as
opposed to counting from the left like
substring is doing
and we can do it on a shorter string so
our studio 147 and it will take those
last three units as well so 147
now where we would actually use
something like this rather than random
strings is you might imagine you have a
very long data frame and you're trying
to extract ids or something from it so
all of these strings have you know
random lengths but we always want to get
the last three units because that's the
id we're trying to get
so we could take this and maybe we want
to compare the sales against the id
we could you know write custom things uh
10 different times or we could use our
substring right
so with substring write with a mute take
call we can just take our company id
take the last three units and now we
have our id and its own column
so again calling the function one time
having it vectorized across all the
different
or all the different values and getting
just the things we want rather than
having to manually write some type of
thing over and over and over
so that that's kind of the power of
functions
now we're going to skip across that
we've covered a little bit about
functions the next part is like a lot of
people love the tidy verbs a lot of
people love things like dplyr or gt or
gg plot
and what this provides is like a
user-friendly framework for writing you
know our code it's very easy to use
you have to learn one more thing
sometimes though to write functions or
wrappers around these called tidy eval
or tidy evaluation
so you might be familiar with dply r
which is a way of like manipulating data
in r
multiplier verbs use title eval in some
way and tidy eval is a special type of
non-standard evaluation used throughout
the tidy verse
so tight evaluation is kind of a fancy
word for saying
you know empty cars group by cylinder
summarize n is equal to the count
mean is equal to the mean of miles per
gallon
you'll notice that cylinder and miles
per gallon are not quoted there's no
kind of quotations around them so
they're bare values
um so with tiny evaluation dplyr knows
to you know find these things inside the
empty car's data frame and reference
them in that way
so while this is super user friendly you
have to kind of supply arguments in the
same way so if you want to write
wrappers around d plier or other things
with tidy val you can do with just in my
opinion two new concepts for the vast
majority of things
so you can embrace your variable with
the two embracers here so you take your
vare in this case like cylinder
and in your function you just put the
curly curly or the embracing operator
around it and then deplier knows to pass
along this and evaluate it in the
context of empty cars
or you can pass the dots which allows
you to pass any named arguments into the
other location so this could be used for
many arguments that you're not really
wanting to capture all of them at the
specific valuation time
and you can always revert back to doing
you know dot data and double brackets
and var if you wanted to use strings
instead of their columns
so let's show this real quickly with
some functions and then we'll go into
packages
so we'll load dplyr and here we're going
to do a car summary function
and all this function is doing is allow
you to group by specific variable and
then get the average and the count so
take empty cars grouped by and we're
using our embracing operator with these
double brackets around there
and then it has summarize and this part
can be done with you know normal syntax
so when we call car summary on empty
cars versus it will group by the number
of uh if it's a
v
organized engine and that's zero or one
and it gives us the average in the count
or we can try and do this with two
arguments in terms of we can try and do
it with verses and is it automatic or
manual transmission
but here because there only has you know
the ability to take one argument it
fails it says well you know i don't know
what to do with am because it's not
indicated there's there's not a second
var up here it's just one
so in this case we need to pass multiple
things through
so we can use the dots here instead and
there's a question about the dots so
this might be helpful as well
in this case car summary dots has a
function with you know whatever named
arguments you want to pass so the dots
are pulled forward into group by
and then if you use any named arguments
they'll be evaluated in this context
so now we can take our car summary dots
and use as many arguments as we want we
can use versus am cylinder and it will
group by all three of those and give us
the average and the count of each of
these little subgroups
so concept one embracing operator allows
you to take a specific variable and
evaluate it within tidy eval you just
have to put these two brackets around
the actual function argument name and
the dots allow you to pass any kind of
count of observation around
the you know grouping function here
and you can combine these ideas so maybe
you want to you know group by a specific
variable and then pass many different
things into your summarize
so here we can group by there we've got
double you know brackets around it for
the embracing operator and then for dot
dot this allows us to pass new arguments
to summarize
so now we can group by cylinder and then
we can define novel new things so we can
say well i want to get the average of
the horsepower and the standard
deviation of the horsepower as well
and because you're passing the dots the
users can do this you're grouping by
cylinder or whatever other column they
want to group by but then they can
define their own
uh summarization functions within
summarize so a lot of different power
here in combining things whether it's
single arguments specific arguments
passing the dots and for tidy eval
passing the dots or the embracing
operator
so let's do this one more time with
novel data i'm sure that very few people
want to only be using empty cars
so in this case to kind of adhere to the
tidy verse style guide we're going to
try and put data as our very first
argument so this means we can pipe
directly into it so i take the mt cars
data set
and then group by cylinder
and then summarize on mpg
so now rather than you know having our
summarize function do the grouping and
do all the rest of it our summarizing
function is just a wrapper around
essentially summarize
and now we have you know our functions
are men of the ver max of the var and
we're dropping our groups
so we take this we can obviously group
by you know cylinder and empty cars and
then get our summarization but we can
just as easily use a new data frame or
the tooth growth data set that's also
built into r that has you know the
vitamin c or orange juice with pigs and
how long their teeth grow super
interesting data set but
just showing you that you can take
whatever different data you want and
your function doesn't have to kind of
capture the data inside of it you can
supply data as an argument
there are cheat sheets for tidy eval
and we'll cover those in one more slide
i'll show you a couple different links
for learning about that as well as other
functions
so lastly you know if you did want to
work with strings as opposed to bear
call names
then you could do that and you can use
something like the dot data argument in
double brackets and now we're taking
data in our var
and rather than leaving it as miles per
gallon without quotes we're quoting it
and it's being passed into kind of this
more base r
style of subsetting
so that's possible but you know i really
like this idea of like being able to
list things as their own kind of
you know unquoted operations and then
passing them into multiple kind of tiny
evaluated functions something i do a lot
with gt
speaking of gt uh the reason why like i
care a lot about eval is this allows me
to build very specific functions inside
tables so a lot of different things
going on with this function this is
actually from gt extras gt ad divider
what we're doing here and all the
different concepts have been captured we
have our stop if not saying if this is
not found then give me a nice error
message we're passing the dots we have
you know specific arguments here
and all we have to do in terms of
passing columns because it's tightly
evaluated is we do our embracing
operator around columns in the different
locations that's being used
so now i can take my data set pass it
into gte creates a nice table fantastic
and i can then pipe that into gta
divider and without having to wrap
cylinder anything else or treat it like
other data set i can use tidy evaluation
to not have to do my quotes and all the
other fancy things i can do with it
and this allows me to add a specific
divider at the cylinder
but because i've also passed the dots i
can do novel arguments and make it you
know red or heavier or lighter or
whatever i want to do
and i can also pass multiple arguments
so i can do you know combine
uh cylinder and miles per gallon and now
i have a barrier on or divider on miles
per gallon and cylinder along with all
these other transformations i've done
so a lot of different power here with
tidy eval because it works across many
different functions
and specifically with things like dply r
that allows you to translate things from
r to say like
a database like sql or spark
so by using tiny evaluation you not only
get to not have to quote things but you
can pass them into other contexts which
is extremely important
so we've talked a lot about functions
you might be thinking well i'm always
here to learn about packages but the
idea here is that to build packages you
have to write functions so i think it's
really important to talk about a bunch
of different ways of doing that and if
you want to learn a little bit more
about general functions these are some
great resources about just writing
functions and how they work
if you want to think about more about
how do i name or style or organize my
code there's the titimer style guide
and if you want to learn all there is to
know about tidy evaluation and if you
even really need it you can look into
these different things so tidy
evaluation the book things about the r
language and how it works programming a
d player or gg plot lots of different
use cases there where you can explore
we've talked a lot about building
functions
so let's jump into building packages and
why you might actually write these
functions
so more realistic internal functions you
might use like i mentioned is you can
use dplr to connect to databases so
maybe you use sql a lot of work you can
actually use dbplier and wrappers around
dply or dbplier to write functions that
query against a production database and
pull data in
or maybe you have you know data that you
get every week and you have to clean it
the same way every week you could write
a function to do that cleaning step and
make it you know one line of code as
opposed to copying and pasting 30 lines
of code around
maybe you want to create a theme for
your plot or your table or use specific
color themes or logos or even specific
data you're bringing in
write a function to generate an entire
report
write a function for reusable shiny
functions that you can use across the
different you know applications you're
writing
or scaffolding or wrappers around common
machine learning tasks so if you're
always writing you know training testing
use this function you could write a
wrapper around all of that
basically anything you do repeatedly and
want to repeat or test without having to
redo it manually that's an argument for
writing a function and eventually taking
that function into an r package
as hillary parker says in her you know
introduction of packages from a while
back seriously it doesn't have to be
about sharing your code or getting your
code on crayon although that's an
amazing added benefit
it's about saving yourself time
any time you can write a function you're
being lazier in a good way rather than
having to worry about you know copy
pasting this code all around you now
have a function with very specific
purpose with very specific arguments
that you can reuse over and over and
over
i also want to give a shout out to emily
reuterer she wrote a great
blog post about building a team of
internal r packages so if you're
thinking about how do i use this at work
or how do i go even deeper
she's got a lot of you know amazing
ideas written here about
how you can actually integrate this into
an enterprise environment and kind of
build out a team of internal r packages
that all work together
so let's jump back to package
development we'll use the remaining time
to talk specifically about packages now
that we've covered a good chunk about uh
you know our functions themselves
so argument one and something i hear a
lot of time you know why do i write a
package why can't i just like source
code you know just use the base r source
function to pull code from somewhere you
know i'm just i have it on my drive or i
have it on you know github and i just
read the source code in
so source references a very specific r
file reads it all in and executes it and
you could use this to add a function to
your environment
but
sourcing doesn't know anything about the
versioning of the code in terms of
you're not using a specific package
version you're literally just reading in
text and then evaluating it in r
it doesn't have you know included
testing or structure around it it
doesn't have included documentation that
both you can use and other people who
use the code can use
and it requires the r file to be copied
into every project that needs it so if
you use it in one project then move to
another one you have to read the file
back into that and what if you change it
up stream so if you need to make those
changes and those changes can be made in
every project that needs it
and it could be modified or deleted
accidentally by the end user or
collaborator so maybe a collaborator
says okay well i'll just change this one
part it'll make it easier for me
you go back to use it you read in the
dot our file and nothing's working
so
overall it's just you know sourcing is
fine in terms of like if i'm just
sourcing a dot our file so that i'm you
know being more compact with my code but
packages basically
solve all those different problems for
you and provide all these different
things that you need
so a package in terms of what we're
thinking about the anatomy of a function
let's talk about the anatomy of a
package now
the metadata is basically the
description the name of the package a
description of the package's purpose the
version of the package and any package
dependencies so again this structure
allows you to
install it and share it with others and
have them be able to essentially
recreate that same environment that you
want to be evaluating things in
it has source code via dot r files that
live in the r directory
it has special oxygen comments inside
the dot r files that describe how the
function operates as well as its
arguments dependencies and other
metadata
it has the name space basically saying
here's the functions that you're
surfacing in your package and here's
imported functions you bring in from
other packages
and then it also can have things like
tests that confirm your function works
as intended so when you change things in
your function or if you add something
new you kind of confirm to yourself and
others hey i haven't broken the whole
rest of my package or the whole rest of
my code
so this is kind of the minimal anatomy
of a package you could go further you
could have data you could have vignettes
you could have examples all sorts of
other things but we're going to start
with kind of that mvp or that minimal
viable package for what we're going to
do today
so all these other things in terms of
installed files compiled you know code
from c plus or javascript or whatever
else
we're not going to worry as much about
that today and focus more on this kind
of minimal parts of a package
so while writing packages and you know
you think well there's four things i
have to learn the tiny first team has
spent years crafting meta packages to
make their life and your life easier to
create other packages so these packages
are used every day by thousands of
package developers and really do make
things easier with functions because
you're writing packages and writing
components of packages with these
functions with very specific purposes
so the two packages we'll talk about
today dev tools the purpose of this is
to make package development easier by
providing our functions that simplify
and expedite common package building
tests
and use this which is a workflow package
again automating repetitive tasks that
arise during project setup and
development both for our packages and
non-packaged projects
so these are sub-linked in the slides so
if you go to this
link for the packages
and then you can go to each of them and
kind of explore them deeper but we'll
talk about them a little bit today
so we've talked a lot about slides we've
talked a lot about packages talked a lot
about functions let's build a demo
package real quickly in five minutes
so let's go to our studio this is where
i was building the slides for today
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a new project so within our
studio i can create a package in this
way so i can go new project
and now i'm going to say i'm going to
create a new working directory
i want to create an r package
and i'll give it a fun name so fun name
is what we'll call our package and it's
going to do all the cool things we want
to do
so i'm going to create this project
it's going to switch over to this new
project
that we want to work in so rather than
package building we now have our new
project a fund name
because we created as a project it's
already pre-populated with a lot of the
different things we need it even gives
us a nice friendly little hello world
function saying like here's how to write
a basic function and some useful
shortcuts in our studio or wherever else
to install check or test these packages
so i'm going to delete my namespace
because i want to build that from
scratch
and i'm actually going to delete this
hello world example because we're going
to build our own function real quick
so
let's start off we're going to clear
this we're going to do use this
use r
and this is basically saying create an r
function with a specific name so let's
do square
val
when i do this it will create you know
this dot r file for square val and then
i can you know do fun if i type just the
short shortcut here in our studio it's
going to give me the snippet which is
built in and i can say square val
x
x
squared
now i have my function you know square
val so square val 2 and that's 4.
square val
16. 256. great
but rather than you know reading it in
that way we can actually use
dev tools load all
and this will load the entire package
and potentially dependencies within it
so i can do the same thing of square val
2 whatever it's been loaded but in the
context of a package as opposed to me
just you know reading in and saving
something a function as an r object in
my local environment
now another part in terms of
documentation and i'm just going to kind
of abbreviate this and saying that i'm
going quickly and we're going to go
through all these steps in the slides
just trying to show you how quickly you
kind of move through this process
so i can use command shift p
and i can say i want to insert a oxygen
comment so insert a oxygen comment
and this will give you this scaffolding
for all the different things so you know
my function is
square a value
a numeric value to be squared
it returns a number
and for example square val 2
perfect
so now
when i actually am ready to go i can say
dev tools install
and it's going to install my package
and it's it's going to install
everything it's going to take a second
because because i'm streaming
everything is going so let's enter that
and because i'm live streaming i've got
to do one step so let's restart
everything
and devtools document
devtools document is basically going to
say you know we've done something with
this r function update the documentation
so it's going to rewrite some of the
documentation
now let's do dev tools install again
it's going to take my package and
install it locally for me
so now in the context of you know this
environment that i've done i can re load
fun name
and i have my package loaded and i can
do something like tell me about square
val with the question mark and just like
any other r package that you install
from github or crane or anything else
i've now gone from no package to
creating a package to creating a
function to installing my package and it
has documentation about it
so in this short span i've created
something that i can use in any other
project and i'm ready to go i have my
package
obviously there's more we can do with
this we probably want more than one
function we want you know better
documentation or we want to share with
others but i just want to very quickly
show you that like in the span of a few
minutes you can create your function
create your package and have it working
for yourself locally
so now that we've kind of
hopefully kind of motivated you to kind
of take that next step let's talk a
little bit about what we just did and
talk about the individual components so
you feel comfortable building on it
so we created a blank package
so i use you can either use use this
create package or from within our studio
i just clicked open new directory open
our package and then gave it a very
specific name and then that actually
created my package in my environment
that i could work with and then install
so you can kind of get started from
there either way is fine
so now that we have kind of a new
project that is set up as a package
we're gonna go through the whole game
essentially creating a package
end-to-end creating an r function
creating the package the documentation
and some basic testing
so for the whole game we're going to use
those two packages i was talking about
devtools and use this those are
available on crayon you can install them
with install.packages and again these
just make some of the process a lot
easier so rather than having to manually
learn all the different pieces you can
just use these functions to build out a
lot of the boilerplate or reused
components
i do want to take a break here in terms
of saying like part of the way that you
can share packages is through version
control and you know i'm never going to
try and shame anyone or throw shade in
anyone but this is the kind of the best
way to share packages and you probably
should be using version control for your
r packages so you can
you know step back and forth and
collaborate and when you're working on
your production packages and production
code
you can check them into version control
and understand like how changes were
made over time when they were changed
you know documentation about the changes
and collaborating on their development
at our studio we you know typically
default to using git and a lot of us use
github but other folks use things like
svn bitbucket git lab whatever you're
using is great version control is
fantastic and any way you can get
started with version control is great
a lot of the functions and use this are
closely tied to github specifically
because that's what the tidyverse team
uses so they're writing things that
they're familiar with and things that
they're using
so in that package we are using we can
actually do use this use get and this
will actually add you know get into that
component and we can start tracking our
changes over time
you can also do something like use this
use github or use git lab or use
whatever to you know start referencing
it on a remote repository so git
initially is local
this version control remotely is
something like github which is based off
the cloud or git lab off the cloud or
bitbucket which is an enterprise like
on-premise version of git
just in general
version control will allow you to take a
package and share it with the world via
something like github or git lab or
other people can install it
to read a lot more about version control
and specifically how to use get with r
please see happy get with r by jenny
bryan another great resource that kind
of help you get there
all right
so again the kind of the first step i
did in my new project was use this use r
and this is me basically saying hey i
want to create a minimal r function and
then open it for interactive editing
so i'm going to do square val dot r and
this will create a function it will open
it up with basically me ready to go and
that was the first thing i did was you
know use this user
at this point you could copy over some
code you're using or you could write it
all inside that environment it's just
another dot r file you know you can do
whatever you want in there and
interactively code interactively edit
just you don't have to create a manual
file you can just use this user and get
started really
quickly the next step i did once i wrote
a function that i was like i think this
is working let's test it you know i
could highlight that code and load it
into my environment
or the better option is dev tools load
all
because we're working in a package
environment you may actually write
functions that are depending on other
functions you've written
so in this way you can load all the
functions together in the context of the
r package and it's not going to load
them as specific objects in the global
workspace it's kind of doing something
behind the scenes
but this devtools load all loads all the
different functions you have in your r
package all at once so you're kind of
ready to go this is really helpful when
your our package suddenly has like 10 or
15 or 100 functions in it and you want
to load all of them and interact with
them
again for version control once we've
confirmed the minimal function is
working we should probably commit our
changes and you can do that via the
built-in git pane or via the terminal
for github
so if i'm inside my r function my r
package again i can use this use git
and it's going to ask me if i want to
commit them yes we've done initial
commit
and then in our studio i have this get
pane at the very top for version control
and this will allow me to kind of
interact with things but okay well i've
changed some parts and i can do commit
messages and pulls and pushes and basic
changes there
so you can use that or if you're
comfortable using it from the terminal
you can do all sorts of get commands
from the the terminal there's really no
difference in terms of the end result
all right
so we've created a function we've loaded
it and used it we've checked in into git
or version control
but you know we want to make sure it's
working so how do we go about checking
the function you know again we have
evidence that the function works because
we've used it and we interactively
loaded it and used it but how can we be
sure that all the different components
of the package still work it might seem
silly after you've only done one
function to check it but it's good habit
to establish the habit of checking this
very often because you want small
moments of friction as opposed to you've
written all these different things and
you check it or test it and you're just
overwhelmed with the output
so we can use dev tools check and this
will use kind of
it will load the package check the
package and uses all these known best
practices so if you go to our r function
dev tools check
so this is going to load it it's going
to do a bunch of different things and
you'll see a lot of things passing
through it's meant to be used
interactively in terms of it's telling
you all the different components and you
can read through it as you want
and it's going to tell you warnings
failures errors and all sorts of other
things and it's just checking all this
massive stuff for you so you don't have
to manually go through and check all
these components you can actually look
at the different things as noted
so it's got a couple different errors
so it's looking for the hello function
that one i deleted so we're gonna have
to remove that it's giving me a warning
saying that hey the there's no license
on here
and it's saying that the hello function
is documented but on the code so we need
to fix those things in terms of it's
telling us issues about the package
without us mainly having to
check it with our own kind of eyes we
can look through here and get the actual
output
so the output of this function is really
verbose it's doing a lot of different
things and for the vast majority of the
time they all go yes you know if you set
up a project in the way that i've showed
you and kind of with you know our studio
it's ready to go and it's got all the
different components however there's
still mistakes you can make in terms you
saw i had some errors and warnings and
other things
so it's really good to run this
frequently so i can make changes and fix
things in the moment rather than having
to do it a lot later and having this
overwhelming amount of changes to make
now the one specific thing that it
showed us and it kind of gave this error
was now this function works fine but we
haven't added a license which check will
throw as a warning
and this license is because i'm using
open source code and anyone can see it i
need to provide a license basically
telling people how they're allowed to
use it you know what are they allowed to
do with it are they allowed to copy the
code and use it in their own package
like how do they reference it
it might seem silly to you know add a
license if you're not showing it to
other people
but even within your own org you should
at least define the license so that your
wishes are respected and it's clear as
to reuse and ownership of the source
code
the software licensing is really complex
and luckily we don't have to like
redefine things there's common patterns
i typically default to use mit license
but other people use other licensing
there's a few different resources here
for talking about
why you should choose a license how
choose a license what they actually do
and i highly suggest if you're gonna you
know use a different license check out
what they do what they mean at these
different resources
now
another step you saw me do was you know
i wrote my function i added the oxygen
comments which were those little
indicators or the documentation at the
top
wouldn't it be nice you know if you
documented how your function works and
you were able to get help like you were
with other functions so if you did you
know question mark on your functions
they actually told you what they're
going to do
so this requires that you have
documentation
but again rather than having to write
all the r specific dot rd files that are
kind of like latex you can just use
roxygen to generate those automatically
so in our studio you can go to the code
panel and do insert oxygen skeleton or
what i showed was with the command
palette on our studio 1.4 or later you
can just do command shift p
and say you know insert oxygen skeleton
and it will show you the different parts
so let's go here if i go to code
there's a bunch of different things
going on and i can insert oxygen
skeleton
as long as i'm within a function in
terms of within these arguments here
when i go to code
insert oxygen skeleton it will give me
these different comments that i filled
in above
or
i could do command shift p to open this
command palette i say insert or oxygen
comment and as i filter this down it
allows me to do the same thing insert a
rock section comment
and then if you want to memorize it
there's this longer shortcut i like
using command palette because i can just
type in what i want to do and i don't
have to memorize you know 15 or 100
different shortcuts i just use one and
then raw text
now as far as what documenting is doing
is you're basically letting your code
breathe on its own you're
self-describing the code with roxygen
and specifically oxygen 2 like the the
modern version of this
so the premise of oxygen 2 is simple
describe your functions and comments
next to their specific definitions
and roxygen will process the source code
and the comments and generate those rd
files for you as well as update the name
space and potentially update the
description
so again rather than you having to learn
these 10 new things you just learn how
to write oxygen comments and that
generates the downstream documentation
that our package needs to operate
if you want to go really really deep on
oxygen there's a nice intro to oxygen
you can go through
but the basic ideas we'll talk about
right now
so roxanna
items are basically special comments
in terms of a normal comment is just a
pound sign or a hashtag
and a oxygen comment is a pound sign
with a single quote behind it
and then you give it specific things
that you're changing so you do like an
at param
this is the parameters or the arguments
for your package
so i say a parameter an argument and
then describe that that argument so for
square val 2 it was a numeric input that
will be squared
now while that basic idea you can kind
of repeat it over and over and you can
change out like add param argument and
all the different at uh things you can
change with through oxygen
there and it can seem overwhelming in
terms of oh i still have to know all
these different things there's really
only a few things that are necessary to
again build that minimum viable package
you're going to give the title of the
function with that title
you can give a description of the
function purpose with at description
you can document the function arguments
with that param
and you can specify it for export with
export
and if it requires other packages you
can either globally import all of those
or import specific packages from other
specific functions from other packages
and then tell our what is the function
return
again when i inserted this basic roxygen
skeleton it basically gave me the
minimal viable components so i didn't
have to type out param return explorer
examples i just described them
you know it already said hey this
parameter is x
so i just describe what x is and it
returns something so i say it returns a
number and i'm yes i do want to export
it
and for examples i'll just you know use
the most basic one square val2 but i
could also do square val 16 and however
many examples you want to put in there
it will execute those
so while it's not required to add those
examples those can be really helpful you
know if i call
you know question on our norm
for example it tells me a description
the title and then it has some usage
but then here in the examples it also
gives me some common ways people use it
you know like maybe you generate random
data and then you plot it or you create
a ter
a curve in base r or
if you want to do like error functions
so it basically gives you some context
about how people use it as opposed to
just documenting what the what the
function does
so those examples are really helpful
so let's you know show a full-blown
example in terms of a title description
parameter return export examples all the
different minimal kind of common items
so again these are special comments they
have the pound sign and then
a quote
so for the title take a numeric value
and square it
for the description
this function takes a numeric value and
squares it it's intended to be used as a
replacement for value squared
for the one argument it has so param
argument a numeric input that will be
squared it returns a numeric value yes i
want to export it so when people load my
package this function is loaded
and for the examples square valve 4
which returns 16 it will actually show
in the documentation because it will
evaluate that function
so while as you build more complex
packages or more complex examples you
might expand upon this
in short you're able to add kind of a
ready to go function that's pretty well
described just by adding these specific
components
and then when you devtools document this
and install the package you can do like
question mark square val and it will
give you all of this in the pretty way
that r displays it in the help panel
so now that we've added these rocks and
comments we basically need to update the
documentation for the metadata so if we
do devtools document it will read
through all the different dot r files
and write out that documentation for you
and then just as expected you can do you
know question mark square val
and it will show you all that
documentation you wrote so you get to
immediately see the benefits of your
labor and other people downstream will
be very excited to actually figure out
what does this function do and how do i
use it
so while this is great it's done some
more behind the scenes work beyond just
you know the help panel it's also added
the square valve function as an export
in the namespace file
the namespace is something we don't want
to edit by hand
again it's a downstream thing that you
know devtools document and roxygen do
for you
but this basically just tells the
package yes we're exporting square val2
so if i go back to r
and i can go into my package and you can
look at the name space
it has export square val just like we
expected because we've documented the
package it's added our function as an
export so when i load the package it's
available
now we can dev tools check one more time
and make sure we haven't missed anything
or that something hasn't broken and then
we'll basically again go through that
whole process of checking it for errors
or warnings or issues
and we're going to check it into version
control we're going to commit basically
very early very often basically whenever
we're making these changes and we're
ready to kind of commit them into
version control
make that commit and then you can always
kind of go back to that moment in time
when things were working if you break it
downstream
all right
so we've documented our package we've
created our functions now we can
actually install it and basically make
it available on any our session within
our computer
so dev tools install when you run that
inside your specific project we'll
install that package locally meaning
even though you know i've been doing
everything inside function name i can
actually go back to my package building
project
load my package and use it there i don't
have to source the file in i don't have
to reinstall it it's just available
so if i do
[Music]
fun name i think yeah square val 2
i can call this in this this package and
this other uh i can call the package
in this environment even though it's a
different environment that package has
been installed so i'm ready to go i can
use this
for other people they need to install it
from version control in terms they need
to download all the things and compile
and build it themselves which is fine
but for me i'm ready to go i've created
a package that's useful for me and i'm
happy with it
as you'd expect i can load it in any
other environment i can load demo
package or package fund name or whatever
else i want and then i can use the
functions as i needed to
now in most situations you probably want
to add a lot more functions you're not
just sticking with one function you have
10 functions you want to use or 100
functions or however many you can think
up and and get ready to go
so we can add all of our functions with
a similar workflow use this
use r define the function
write the function make sure it's
working add documentation and you're
ready to go
again checking all these different
components in the version control as you
go but because we've already covered
that i want to jump on to the next thing
which is let's add some tests
so for the sake of time and while we can
add all those different functions with a
similar workflow we should talk about
testing our function to test that
because we want to show the whole game
you want to show like all the different
components
so testing is basically and test that
our way of doing unit testing
and you've been doing
uh unit testing
essentially all the time whenever you
test your your ideas so if i do like
you know function x
i probably want to do it that way if i
say like one plus one
equals two i've now checked myself on
making sure one plus one equals two i've
just done it in the r console so it's
only useful for me at that moment in
time and i have to remember everything
before i do square val 2
and if i actually uh do fun name
and actually bring in the function it
gives me four
and if i do three it should give me nine
so i i'm testing it and it's it's you
know going along with what i want it to
be doing
but
six months from now
i don't remember if it actually did what
i wanted it to do
so by adding tests i can basically you
know make these tests occur with code
automatically as opposed to me having to
test it in the r console or manually or
interactively
so whenever you're attempting to type
something into just like a print
statement and be like okay yep it gave
me what i want or a debugger expression
write it as a test instead
so up until now we've only tested our
function interactively literally used in
our console and check for package errors
via check
we can formalize and expand this with
unit tests via the test that package
again just a user friendly package
making it easy to write tests in r and
basically check your assumptions
a unit test and r basically means we're
expressing very specific expectations
about our example so we want square val
2 to always generate squared values and
we can test that with a couple different
inputs
as far as unit tests
i came from a neurobiology background i
had never used the unit test until i
started writing packages so it was a new
term to me
unit tests are basically automated tests
run and written by developers to ensure
that their application or their unit of
code behaves as intended
so by writing these tests for small
components and then adding up all the
tests together you can basically test
very complex objects
and with very simple tests
so let's do this real quick in terms of
use this as a workflow package just like
everything else there's a use test that
so we can load use this and then use
this use test that
this will create a test file for
whatever file you open
so let's go back to our
function name
i do see a question in the chat about
the console prompt um
i actually have a tweet about that in an
example i need to write a blog post
about it but
i will
yeah so this is part of my our profile
it basically says like what is today's
date it gives me some kind of
motivational examples and says like what
art version are you using and then every
time i add something or the time changes
and i executed something in our console
it gives me the current time a nice
little laptop emoji and tells me which
branch i'm working with
this is probably beyond today's scope
but i will promise i'll tweet out about
it again about how to do this there was
a great example from someone in the
community on how to how to do that
but we're going to be talking we're
going to focus again on unit testing so
i'm going to use this
use test
now you'll note that before i call this
function i want to go to the file i have
open
it will basically say whatever file i've
opened interactively create a test for
that
and it's going to tell me a little few
things that are going on it's adding
test that to suggest it's creating a
test folder it's writing the test file
and now it opens this up
now we have a test that function which
is basically you know it defaults to
this example which is test that
multiplication works
and i need to load test that so library
test that
we'll call that again
and it gives me this happy yeah
multiplication and r still works 2 times
2 is 4. great that's good but we're
interested in square vowel
actually squares
all right so let's do
square val
and we want to square
2
expect equal
four
all right so what we're doing here is
saying test that these different things
are expected so we're going to expect
that square val 2 returns four
and when i test that
let's see what it says it says could not
find function square val so dev tools
load all
and the reason why i did that is because
i moved into this uh project and didn't
do anything yet but if i do test that it
will say test pass and it will always
give you a happy little message every
time it passes
but what if something doesn't match so
what if we say
square val 4 is 15 instead of 16.
so we run this and now it gives me a
failure and it says square val actually
squares so the text i have up here
the actual is not equal to the expected
the actual should be 16 but it returned
15.
so now i can basically generate many of
these different tests that test
different components by package
and tell me oh yeah by the way like that
thing that you thought was working is
not working and it failed in this exact
way and whenever someone opens an issue
and says hey your package is failing you
can write a test for it to make sure it
doesn't happen in the future
now most of the time when you're writing
these functions initially they just work
and that's great like you've written a
function that works
but these unit tests allow you to
standardize how you're making sure it
actually does what you want
now again there's many different things
so maybe you don't want to expect equal
you actually want to expect failure
so
let's say expect failure what happens if
we square a cat
you know it's halloween we're going to
be squaring some cats what happens then
so uh
so expect failure function name square
valve cat
so i'm forgetting how to do that so
let's do expect failure the joys of life
so expect failure
message equals null
and let's
do that let's do expect failure let's do
this one we're going to do live
ah
okay so it's giving me
i forget so you have to do this
the way that expect failure works and i
blanked for a second is
equals to this i believe is what we're
doing square operator
we don't want this we want cat
i'm going to check my assumptions then
we're going to go into it but this is
all the joy of live coding snapshot so
let's do
comma
and
we're going to do
this
inspect equal
i've changed a couple different things
but i just want to make sure it's
working before all right
non-american
square bow cat
all right fun times so
as some of the people in the chat are
saying i'm having a failure here but
let's go back to this let's let's let's
just keep going we're a little over time
so we're just going to keep going we'll
have some fun with this
um so
expect failure message equal
expression
cat
what am i doing here
square valve cat
doing fun things
so the basic idea of how expect failure
is supposed to work is that if you get
an error it's going to error
and let's say that the message equals
non-numeric
binding i think i was just copy pasting
the part because i'm not thinking
uh
message equals non-numeric
error
error in x
squared
no numeric operator
uh all right
so
not working but
good times all right so
let's go one more test that
and it's still not working so what i can
do is i know where there is one that is
working let's go to that so we're going
to keep live streaming i'm not going to
save that test we're going to go to gt
extras because this is where i have all
my actual production tests
so
the
fun times about live streaming so now
i'm in my own personal package this is
actually a package that i use a lot
for writing uh r functions
so let's uh find
expect failure
do i even have one in here
fail
here
i can spell failure
apparently i haven't written one of
those before so we'll just gonna abandon
that for now and go back to the slides
and if i have time at the end i'll keep
exploring
again the idea is that we can use this
use test that to get our expectations
there is a way to test for errors that
i'm blanking on right now but i want to
keep going rather than getting us off
track
and the way that tests are written is if
we saw that that
let's go to test again
so we're going to test test that
let's do dot bar
so this is a more complex test in terms
of like we're testing svg and html but
the way this is set up is we have you
know a r file that is doing tests of the
specific function
it's creating an object
and then we're doing expect equal i'm
basically saying like do these values
match my expectation
and that's the way that it's set up
so i've created that would use this use
test that
and these expectations are grouped into
those tests or that dot r file
so an expectation is the specific unit
of testing you know does it have the
right value the right class does it
produce error messages
what does it kind of give as the output
these expectations are functions that
always start with expect so i was using
expect equal and the one that i failed
on which is kind of ironic is expect
failure
and then you have a test which is a
group of multiple expectations
so if i were to you
you know
go back to function name we'll go there
for a second the tests are the the
overall kind of parent of all those
different testing that i'm doing or
expectations with the error message
you know that's one unit of
functionality is a test has multiple
expectations and as long as those are
all true or all met you get your happy
uh happy message out
and then the file is grouping together
the test which is grouping together all
those expectations
so if we do this test this whole file is
the test file
test that is the actual test
and these expectations or these expect
equal
are the units of testing so again we'll
load test that
we'll do test that test equal and as
long as it expects
could not
we'll do dev tools load all
going all the way here because we moved
into our new thing so we got it loaded
up
test has passed happy days we got it all
the way back so we have a test file we
have an expectation which is expect
equal
it's your expression and the expectation
and then the testing that you're doing
around that with the message if it fails
all right
so interactively you can write and check
those tests so i can again load all load
test that and i can run this
interactively as i've been showing in
terms of like i do this and it gives me
happy message i do this one and it
expects ah
this is why i was doing expect error not
expect failure here we go
so uh good time so let's do this one
more time i should just kept going on my
slides
test that uh
and because we haven't written square
val2
this is square vowel
and
binary operator so square
val cat
and this is what it gives me this is the
error message the way that expect error
should go
is it should give me the exact message
because we're trying to test for a
message
and it's still going to give me a
failure let's do one more
expect error now it's passing
so with this expect error instead of
expect failure which was my failure
earlier is basically saying like if i
pass something that it can't operate on
in terms of it can't square a cap
uh it's just going to error so if i
do this it generates an error
i'm expecting it to generate an error
and that all passes so not only can i
square values and get the expectation i
can square the value of something that
can't be squared and it gives me the
error that i want to get
so we went full circle we made it all
the way around thanks for sticking with
me on that i'm glad we were finally able
to square our cat
now the way that these tests are written
you can see that i've done a few
different things so for my expectations
i have you know 2 should be equal to 2
squared 4 should be 4 squared 16 equals
16 squared
so i've written essentially like
multiple tests testing the same idea but
with different inputs
because while one input might always
work
did other inputs might not work and this
is probably more impactful for more
complex functions but we want to test
our expectations multiple different ways
and then i can do tests that non-numeric
or missing input should error
so a should always error as input must
be numeric factors data frames missing
values those should all error out in
specific ways
and for expect error
you can either do it as just give me an
error or give me this specific error
message as it's expecting that
i'm writing this on square val 2 which
is the one that had the little helper
function saying
if it's given give me a nice friendly
output in terms of input must be numeric
rather than this kind of less helpful
error non-numeric argument to binary
operator so kind of coming full circle
those tests again optional but useful
live and test slash test that names must
start with test and as far as a usable
test file
this is basically the exact same thing
we're doing interactively but now we've
put it into our testing file
and the reason why it's useful in a
testing file is i can do
dev tools load all
dev tools test
and now it's going to go through and run
my tests and it gives me a okay i have
two passes because it basically
evaluated this and it evaluated square
valve
so in this case when i have the
situation of i have dozens of functions
or 10 functions or 15 functions rather
than again manually going in there i'm
able to go in and test all of them at
once figure out which ones pass which
ones fail which ones have warnings or
other messages
and when i run devtools check
again that thing that i should be doing
very frequently to say like how is my
overall package looking
it will again run all of the tests that
i've written and test that
so what happens if they don't match
again it'll throw this error message so
that was that one if i would have kept
going in my slides or i've been trying
to live code it all out
expect error you know give me this you
know squaring of this and the input must
be numeric so you can still test things
that should always fail or should always
error in a specific way
so you can still get those expectations
and test both successes and failures in
your package
and if you do something that doesn't
match it will again show you that
message of like you tried to square
something it wasn't a match and here's
the difference between the expectation
and the actual value
so well again i've gone through a lot of
the different components of testing and
we went through kind of a side path that
i appreciate you sticking with me with
on writing expect error versus expect
failure
you can read a lot more about this in
the r packages book there's a testing
chapter and test that test that
documentation
and i wrote out kind of a longer form
blog post example of robust testing
let's move on to some more documentation
though
so while
you might you know be relying on built
into our uh kind of documentation you
can also build your own package down
site just like the one for dev tools
that they have they've got this really
fancy you know
cool dev tools package downside with
like documentation and links and
articles and all these cool things
they didn't write all this out manually
in terms of like this was built through
the package down package
so you can do the same thing just with
the documentation we've done we can use
devtools build site
and it will actually build out that
website for us with the documentation
and all the examples
so we'll let that run for a second it's
going to build out the documentation
but the benefit here is that
documentation you've written ahead of
time is used here so every time you run
devtools document
it will you know update this as well
so i can go into reference i click on
square value and it says hey this is
square value and it shows me how it's
supposed to work and it shows me the
examples
so
if you do square val 2 it gives you the
output so again like in literally
seconds i was able to go from writing a
package writing some documentation to
now having a website i can publish other
people can go to and get information
about how my package works
and this is how like my personal
packages have their own documentation so
for like gt extras when you go to the
reference page i didn't have to manually
build out documentation for all these
functions
you know i was able to go in
and you know write the documentation
with roxygen and it builds out all this
complexity for me with like examples and
all the different parts of the code and
everything else
so very very powerful
things you can do with package down in
just the basic documentation
so let's go back to the slides
go back here
so i think this is really powerful i'm a
big fan of that
you can host that package down
output anywhere you can do it on like
github pages is where one of my examples
is
or you can host it on something like
rstudio connect which again if you're
building packages inside your
organization
you may not want to show the entire
world you might just keep them inside
your organization but you can host that
html anywhere
for you know if i was hosting an example
of like one of my basic packages on our
studio connect
i can you know load it with this kind of
code which is basically saying like hey
this is a lot of different files take
all of them and deploy to connect
and then here's one running on our demo
server with the hello world example
operates just the exact same way but
just you can take that documentation and
host it anywhere
now the last component we'll talk about
as we're kind of nearing the end here is
what if we want to reference external
packages so i've written everything with
just base arm
the expectation is that while base are
super powerful at some point you're
probably going to bring in another
package whether you wrote it or someone
else wrote it
for example
i wrote a lot of wrapper packages or
right of wrapper functions around gt
that's what this whole entire
package here is all these different
functions are wrappers around the gt
package
so i have to reference gt
as one of the packages i'm bringing in
because i'm essentially importing all
these functions that other people have
written and loading them into my package
so gt add divider was one of the basic
examples we showed when we were talking
about tidy evaluation
now this only works if i bring in things
from gt as well so tab style
cell borders cell body cell column
labels all of that is actually being
brought in from gt
the part that i'm doing is just gt
object
and the actual inputs because it's
wrapping all those other components
so in order for this to work i have to
tell the function hey by the way i
didn't write any of this please bring in
this other package that's really
beautiful and amazing
so now in our rock session documentation
we have the things that you've seen
before title description the function
parameters all those cool things
and then
import from gt and import gt
now i'm importing from gt the magritter
pipe because inside my function i want
to be able to use magruder prime i want
to use it all over because i have really
long functions and i want to pipe things
together
i'm also importing all of gt in terms of
all the functions that are available in
gt are now made available inside my
function so when i do gta divider it's
able to load in all of those functions
and use them
it also adds gt as an import in the
namespace file meaning when someone
installs gt extras it says hey by the
way you also have to install gt for this
package to work so it also downloads gt
and installs it
so again part of this is that with
simple documentation you can build out
all these different components of all
the important things in your r package
when you call devtools
document or do something like use this
use package gt
it will also update your imports in
terms of like i need to import gt i want
to specifically have people bring in
package version equal to 0.3 because
they added in a lot of cool things in
0.3
so when you import or you install my
demo package it also installs gt
so again this structure gives you the
ability to do your documentation and
metadata and attach all the pieces
together in a way that other people know
to do with it and r knows what to do
with it when you try to install it or
load it in other locations
so use this use package is what allows
you to add specific packages to your
documentation
although you can always manually write
this out if i'm in my package let's
that's gt extras we can show it here
so in my
description
whoa
let's zoom out that a little bit
uh
[Music]
so if i pull this down you can see the
gt extras brings in a lot of things
because i need to like manipulate data
with dplyr i'm doing a lot of inline
plots with ggplot i absolutely need gt
to actually build up all these things so
this tells it every time that i install
my package
you can actually import the specific one
or you can bring in uh this specific
package at a specific version
i do see a question from uh
the chat it looks like
i thought that you could actually do a
specific version in terms of you wanted
to say equal to 0.5 um but typically i
would say greater than or equal to
and most often greater than
um because someone could actually
install a newer package version so this
means as long as you have 0.8.5 or newer
uh dplyr is actually on version 1.0
so we actually want to
bring in anything where as long as you
have dply r 0.8 or newer on your system
it doesn't have to be installed it can
just import that package
again
the whole kind of summary here as we get
to the end you know we've talked about
documentation we've talked about
building functions building the package
writing all the different components
the basic workflows within a package if
we're summarizing this is remember small
changes committed frequently via version
control if you want to share it with the
world you probably want to check it into
version control so they can download and
install it
and if you do those in smaller
components if you do break something you
can go back earlier in the process
use this use r allows you to add a new
functions as you go
control command alt shift r
or command shift p or however else you
want to do it add the oxygen skeleton
went inside the function
dev tools load all lets you load or
inactively test your new function
and then use this use package for a
specific package you want to bring in to
imports to add that package as a
dependency or something you want to
bring in
use this used version when you're
updating your package so allowing you to
change like oh this is 0.2 package
version it's the very first one i did or
it's 0.2.1 you know versioning your
package so you can install it at a
specific moment in time
and then devtools document to document
the package with your various changes as
you make them so anytime you update the
rock searching comments or other
documentation you need to recall
devtools document to document everything
in the appropriate place
and lastly dev tools check all the time
and dev tools test to check and test the
package so you're making sure that all
the things are working
now again
i've shown a lot of different stuff and
it can still seem a little bit like
there's a lot of different components
going on
all these things don't always have to be
done like if you're not importing
packages you don't have to do that if
you're not checking into version control
you don't have to check it into version
control i'm just trying to show you kind
of the different levels of where you can
go and where you can go in the future
and your minimal viable package can be
done in just a few minutes
if all is well at the end of the day
just install the package and you can use
it locally forever as long as you want
to
and then if you want to update the
package you can again install the newest
version once you've made changes to it
and we'll just overwrite that package
install
now as far as devtools install you know
we've only been installing it locally so
no one else can install my package
that's fine maybe i'm the only person
who's supposed to be using it
but to share with your colleagues
they're going to actually take it from
the remote or from the cloud or wherever
else you have the version control
checked
to install it so for example my gt
extras package and the way you install
it is you would actually remote install
from github from my specific handle this
specific package
so even though all the source code
doesn't live on their computer today
they can instill install that package
from github or git lab or wherever else
and install it into their local
environment
and if you get it under crayon then you
can just do install.packages whatever
the package name is
now you don't have to get things onto
crayon for everything again you might
have packages that are only used
internally or you're only using it for
yourself
so while it's great to kind of shoot for
crane in the future that's not required
for every you know package that you're
building
and again while i'm using install github
because that's where i have it you could
install it directly from git lab or just
from git if you had like a local
environment you're installing it from
um another thing that we use a lot in
terms of like r studio package manager
allows you to host like your packages on
premise
um so that's really useful in terms of
like again if you're not releasing it to
the world you're holding packages
internally you can actually host them on
our studio package manager and install
from there so they're not having to
breach your firewall to install
and package manager whether using our
public package manager which is free
or the on-premise rstudio package
manager which is a paid product is it
has all the different versions available
you can install specific package
versions all the packages are binaries
you can install them very quickly
especially in like a linux environment
so to wrap this up and thanks for
sticking along with me for everyone
we've gone through the end-to-end
process of writing functions with both
base r and with tidy eval
we've created a minimal package in just
a few minutes
we've added more functions to the
package we've documented the package as
well as potentially external
dependencies
we've even covered testing and unit
testing with your package
how to create public documentation
internal to r as well as package down
for documentation that's external to our
just on a website
so we've really covered a lot today and
you may only use components of that
that's fine
really just trying to show that you can
create a package very quickly and you
can build up those components over time
with tasks or documentation external
documentation other packages whatever
you need you can kind of build up over
time as you learn more
so i really do hope that you feel
empowered to create your own package you
can use as many of the best practices as
possible but ultimately once you get
started quickly see that the tooling has
really been written in a way to make the
process very user friendly and really
ready to go with it all
as far as follow-up you can read through
the whole process again in our packages
book
this they have a chapter called the
whole game
which goes through the entire process
basically what we did today but written
out
so this has like a basic packager
building and loading different libraries
creating functions
and all the different things that we did
today
so maybe if you're more of you want to
read through it as opposed to watch a
video you could always go through here
i was really just hoping to provide a
video complement to these type of
resources where you can see some of my
successes and failures in real time in
terms of we struggled a little bit
together with that expect failure
because i was looking for expect error
but overall
very very kind of quick to get started
let me close down some of these
different links again the slides from
today are
available publicly so you can kind of go
to the slides i'll throw those in the
chat again if you just want to look at
it all
or if you want to look at the source
code for how i even built the slides or
some of the other stuff i have that on
my github at the second link i shared
which is here at github.com j thomas
mock slash package dash building
overall 90 minutes we built a package we
looked at a lot of different things we
had a lot of fun
thanks so much for hanging around um if
there are any other questions i'll hang
around for a little bit more and answer
some questions but i think it was a fun
stream and i had a good time so thanks
for hanging out with me again i'll stick
around for a little bit
let me see about these um
[Music]
yeah absolutely thanks so much jen
thanks for hanging out for a while
hope it was helpful
i'm gonna go over here to uh the links i
doubly the
other again like if you talk about
github pages for package down
that's how these slides are hosted
and you can actually build those through
through the package down site
um when importing tigers packages would
you recommend importing the whole tidy
verse or just the individual packages
i would definitely recommend just uh
importing the individual packages in
terms of like
the tidy verse is actually like 20 or 30
packages which have quite a bit going on
and it's a meta package in terms of it's
really just loading those other packages
so for
gt extras for example like i depend on
some components of the tidy verse in
terms of like d plier ggplot you know
tinyverse packages
but i'm not bringing in tidyr i'm not
bringing in lubridate i'm not bringing
in all these other different components
of the entire tidyverse and i don't need
to depend on those and i don't need
users to install all those packages even
though they may already have them
installed locally
um
any any other kind of ending questions
unit testing yeah so in the chat or
sorry i'll post these in the chat but
for unit testing
there's a few uh links on this specific
slide
so this slide has the the references
here so the our packages has a book has
the book itself has a chapter on testing
test that documentation goes into
further examples and then i actually did
a long form example of unit testing in
this blog post
so you might think like oh well he's
only testing square val2 how do i do
more complex testing and that's really
what this blog post is all about is
how do you test an html table
so if i create a gt table it's actually
hundreds or even a thousand lines of
html
and those are more complex to test in
terms like this html
is if i inspect it and actually look at
the html code
it's rather complex in terms of like
this whole section right here is all
that table and it's got all these
different sub rows and different you
know bodies and all these other
different things going on so there's a
lot of code there
but
you can extract all those different
components and when you get to the
actual unit testing
i'm just testing you know let me get to
the very bottom i'm just expecting this
exact string in a very specific location
so expect match or expect equal
you know that this specific component of
the table is equal to this so you can
still get your unit test to be very
simple
um
as far as things that are more difficult
to do or there's a question like what
are the works you've created that cannot
be done with unit testing so something
that's
more
it's available now but like there's
interactive
testing or test snapshots
so you may imagine that rather than
testing specific components you want to
test the entire
html string all at once so you can still
do that with expect snapshot but you
have to like save the file and read it
back in
or something like how do i test ggplot
like how do i test the actual graphic or
the png i'm creating
for that you um usually do like a visual
test although you can still test
individual components that are being
created as normal
all right
so thanks again for everyone's time
we're we're about a little bit over so
i'll upload this to youtube let me stop
screen sharing for a second but
thank you so much for your time and
hanging out with me today i had a blast
i'm going to try and do some more of
these regularly maybe with smaller
topics even i know this was a relatively
big one but we'll talk a lot about
tables i'm sure and other different
things in the future
thanks so much for your time everyone
have a great week stay safe and we'll
see you next time